Now suppose that the teacher gives the error program this example as the second
example, and the teacher also tells the error program this is a positive
example, so these are labeled examples. Here's a representation of the second
example. Again, I have done the variabilization, so the constant here, Brick A,
has been replaced by Brick. This was the current concept definition of the AI
program for the concept of arch. And here is a new example.
How should the AI programmer revise its current concept definition of an arch in
order to accommodate this positive example? Because it is a positive example,
therefore the AI program should try to generalize. So one good way of
generalizing the current concept definition is to drop this link.
If the AI program can drop this link, in that case this will be
the new current concept definition. Note that this current
concept definition covers both the second example, as well as the first example.
This is called the drop-link heuristic. It's a heuristic because as we
discussed earlier, a heuristic is a rule of thumb. So here is what has happened.
When an AI program needs to learn from a very small set of examples,
just one example or two examples, then the possible generalizations and
specializations, the learning space, is potentially very large.
In order to guide the AI program about how to navigate the learning space, we'll
develop some heuristics. The first such heuristic is drop a link if you need to
generalize in such a way that the new concept can cover both earlier examples.
So drop-link heuristic is useful when the structure of the current
concept definition and the structure of the new example have a lot of overlap.
They overlap almost exactly, except for one link that is extra in
the current concept definition. The extra link can be dropped because in the new
definition will cover both the previous concept as well as the new example.